let's move on down to the TV split
between John Goodman and Roseanne Barr
John's opening up about the dark times
after the reboot got canceled and
possibly revealing the faint of
Roseanne's character on the converse
well she's dead to me rest in peace
Roseanne Conner Goodman dropped that
bomb talking about his own character
State of Mind when the connors debuts
later this year telling the UK Sunday
Times it's an unknown I guess he'll be
mopey and sad because his wife's dead we
really just hit it off right from the
jump like we always do now we just make
each other laugh Goodman admits he was
brokenhearted and very depressed by the
abrupt cancelation of Roseanne following
his co-stars racist tweet and reveals he
was surprised at the response while he
describes their relationship as simply
work friends he goes on to the Finbar
saying I know for a fact that she's not
a racist Barr agreed to walk away from
the series she created allowing the rest
of the cast to move ahead with the
Conners Goodman says I sent her an email
and thanked her for that I did not hear
anything back but she was going through
hell at the time and she's still going
through hell when I left the show I
didn't realize how lucky I was I was
ready to leave but this time around I'm
really grateful to be her
[Music]
[Applause]